Hello, Natalia greets you, bad sound and
you're seeing Las Vegas' to a Spaniard, your
digital connection to the world of
entertainment, to whom without being, and today
we begin by talking about one of the
Hispanic singers who has been making music
for more than two decades,
Gloria Trevi brings her tour
simple North American next month where another queen will take the
stage of the buses on
September 16 just in time to
celebrate the independence day of
Mexico this show will be part of his tour
titled isla divina tickets to see
gloria trevi is already on sale
through excess dotcom
and another king of Hispanic music
las vegas is coming' paquita la del barrio
brings her tour the last stop to the
bergen hotel on november 26 you can
also get your tickets through excel
let's talk about the blowout now  of the
year already mentioned several times the
rumbazo cesc is coming to las vegas in
three weeks this will be a festival
formed as a result of the rhythm pride and
heritage of vari  Hispanic cultures and
will feature performances by artists such
as Malú Ma
Prince Royce and the artist you are
seeing on your screens is an
Italian Dominican her name is Yendry. I had
the opportunity to talk to her about
that festival and what it means to her to be a
part of it.
It will be my first time in the sees,
my first time singing there, too,
and I also think that the line up is
very, very
important and there are people
like Maluma Ivy Queen and a
marathon, and Prince Royce is also
another Dominican.  It's like, very important,
so there's a little bit of pressure, but
I'm also happy to be able to represent
my community.
Well, they heard Hendry there. The rumbazo
fes is going to be an unmissable night of
celebration of Hispanic culture.
vegas' events center you get your tickets to
set your dotcom fest on course
well now we continue talking about the
unique entertainment we have here
in las vegas but  This time I want to
introduce you to a Hispanic talent who
continues to leave his mark wherever he goes and
has that wow factor I present to you
Ricardo Alejandro and Cristian comer show
at the Hotel Río welcome guys
also known as real crisis that's
right it's the real crisis the
name of our  group we are
alejandro ricardo and cristian so
we put together the three names and it came out and
'the crisis' perfect when and we are
talking to him a little before we
go on camera and they were against me
a little about his story
we have only been in las vegas for a year  how long
have they been here with the show wow and how long have
they been doing what they are doing so he
clarified that if the software has
been here in vegas for approximately four years it
is in the river hotel where we are
located because of how it is a show
that is going  moving constantly the
artists are evolving so
this time the company hired
us to come here to
present our  our our art is a
very beautiful show the wow
where you find too many things all
in one the joy
of risk because you
have impressive acts you have acrobats
comedy dancers that is, you have everything
in one it is a very beautiful show
I don't know if you can see the photos  He has never
seen the show, I'm going to see it, I'm going to
see it, but when I see these photos and see
everything they've done, they've seen some videos,
what you do is incredible.
What
do you do? Tell us about your experience in
America. It's Katawal. We have
a rather long career. We've
been doing this for approximately 25 years.
We are brothers. We are
Colombian. We live in
Mexico, another country that we love very much.
We had the opportunity to present ourselves
at America's Got.  talent thank
god this went very well people
loved our presentation in total
we were with one of our  These countrymen
have one of the judges, the truth is, I am
very excited to meet Sofia
Vergara,
just like the other judges, because they are
very important, very famous people, but
for us it was an
unforgettable experience, an incredible experience of
being able to participate, not
everyone has that  ease and well,
thank God we had it, it is
something that remains marked on you, it is not something that
should not be forgotten and the people who live or are
going to live that experience is something very,
very beautiful and more than anything I am from
Bolivia so I do not  I can imagine
going to Colombia to be seen at an
international level being seen the pride that
feels how it feels to be Hispanic
selling from Latin America is the USA
even the stage of Las Vegas look at
us thanks to veo we have had the
opportunity to travel much of the
world we have been Europe  asia
north america
we were very young young people of the truth
that it feels very nice to be able to take your
art and show it to other c  ulturas not
only us Latinos but for
example the European people the
American people because this tour right now what
we are in wow is a show that is
for everyone not only for Latinos or
Americans for everything so the
people really danced it is very nice
feel that people show their
affection with the fact
that it is something that they really like
what you are presenting to them is a
ministerial art what are the answers
if they have had any or it has not been possible
is that if they have had any 100 they have
the  The experience of the people of the
Hispanic community when they found out that
you are Hispanic, are
Latin American and are here in Las
Vegas, have noticed some response from me,
many, many, really, that we
have been shocked because
after America's Got Talent,
even during the program, the  people
wrote to us through our social networks and
they supported us how good Latinos great
that I know many things many very
nice messages that  They are marked for you and
when we were to see that we are here
in vegan many people who are going to see the
show that come from other cities not
only see them if they do not come from other parts and
they see us and start screaming and in the end it
happens  A lot of people take pictures with
us, they try to know that they
congratulate us for having
something like that for our participation, it is very
nice that the recognition of the public
I think is the most important thing for
one as an artist,
do they have something that they like from here?
las vegas specifically since they are
practically non-habits the truth is we
haven't known much but the little we
have known yes I really
like it I like it a lot well the whole
area where we work is a very
nice area but we are new so I
really can't  tell you exactly why
all this and speaking of the area where
you work, you work in the river
where we also have a chip in our eyes
and we have seen them and in the videos and so
on  shirt on the fine shirt some
some click word continue to give a little bit
of crossover working with chip in
fingers doing something more capable we put a
little what you do digital well
we do a lot what is the
weight lifting gym this
is something that  we have to make room for
a moment some chipping of no something
this is not in the plans but no one
can
ever tell us the future is uncertain
the future is uncertain that's right there
is nothing guys before asking
me thank you very much for stopping by  around here by the
wheels nothing in Spanish for me it is a
pride to have you as
Latin Americans in our culture in
whatever you are doing more
than anything here on the stage in Las
Vegas it is incredible thank you very much
more than inviting you to go to the
show the same  the show is very
good there they study on social networks
good councilor there we are waiting for you
there this beautiful website is spectacular it
is happening  or there at the hotel river for
your tickets go like this 6 dot com
diagonal shows
well las vegas has arrived here' water
in Spanish thank you very much for your
attention see you next week I
greet you Natalia Barça
[Music]